so right now we are standing in front of
the Dunkin Donuts here on Wilshire and
twelve in Santa Monica and this is a
revolutionary day right now this is the
first opening in Los Angeles and I am so
excited at this Jenna it in six and line
so if you want to take a note of - its
grand opening Tuesday my van
right now it's about we'll see you look
inside there's there's things happening
she's opened the door
okay now I'm gonna do the whole of
everything that I got here for the
stakeout I've got this really great camo
bill to match my camo shirt obviously a
times B I saw here got a nice yellow
pillow a nice pink pillow of course it's
gonna be dark at night time so if out of
my flashlight batteries this is the
battery okay I've got new trademark
batteries holy crap fish thank you tips
cuz you did at these I didn't I just
need a boat also we've got the Lego set
I've been wanting to do this for quite a
while so we just had our first new
friends join us oh my gosh I wish every
house door feel free to go
I can't get over material pull up on me
turn down for somebody who's just
arrived in a cab here they are what do
you have donut see what is this oh my
gosh
break break the news break the news it's
just the menu this is the room I guess
what are you gonna get I mean I want to
oh my gosh nice coffee I went all of it
I'm getting really sleepy things are
happening there's things people are
coming out people are coming in there
how is it tell us everything
the donut hey Jen what time is it 6:30
for 6:30 for what time do we get here
I forgot doesn't matter we're here I've
got this really nice camel a nitrogen
what how this is like it's like a I'm
not I can't even tell it looks like a
ladybug but not red I can't even eat all
this nothing
what real food
I'll have an hour music I think it died
I wonder if it let me use their
electricity you guys will never believe
what just happened the light started on
our first our first Popo
just chillin alright so we're gonna head
to me a pizza place now I've been
ordered pizza it's about let's see what
time is that 757 I've been quite an
experience I mean this is this is
overnight I've met some really nice
people so it makes it a lot more
entertaining which is pretty awesome
wonderful the pizza place is I've
actually been to this place many times
the pizza has been acquired you have
your orders still coming
this is crazy so the time now is 8:30
they were nice enough to give us free
water and the bathrooms are open until
if all the restaurants open till 3:00 so
technically that means they can see my
friend gonna be my YouTube video thanks
for everyone I'm already getting tired
I'm fading guys fading hello are you
getting in line actually if everybody
can hear me a neighbor has called
already complaining about noise oh okay
all right thank you
I think the cheering is probably that
would do it well silence here's your
lines fine beginning of line and all the
way down
it is now 1007 gentleman back to the
house to pick up a few things and I'm
gonna go back to how my blood this is
the worst the worst chair I've ever felt
in my life
okay I'll be right back so I was able to
go back and change and now I'm seeing
all the people across the street like
there's a photographer here he's taking
photos oh my god zoom in on em you take
picture of me I think that your unibrow
real comfy no you get up it killed you
guys are curious next time so this is a
way
Oh guys what is it Long Beach on
Wednesday no not a week one a month one
a year
it's too heavy to hold up
so right now the time is 1252 and the
line is wrapping all the way around the
building there's a there's a lot of
people here hi
I took my contacts out so I can't see
any of you okay we're taking a pee break
we just chatted with Cohen Lotte [__]
was a Queen Latifah producer producer
everydays art I Laura and I gonna pee at
Subway I gotta go I gotta go I gotta pay
to go subway it's true weapons like
almost on it
who are you what about you didn't exist
are you is he huh
he's the truck man yeah should I put
shoes on I was trying to you the key
need to get in the door
nothing it's been happening for the past
six out actually are you drunk
you can get a do cut you go oh I'm
reporting live on the scene yeah I
should probably suck okay some things
are coming off the truck we're not sure
what's coming off the truck so I'm going
down here to to see what's going on oh
my gosh what's coming off the truck
oh my god it is like a heavenly whiff
the cops are here okay Don wait taking
pictures yeah because we just the air
we're because okay I've been told this
is happening
we've already here's the thing we're
gonna bring you all like beer and wine
and cocktails this guy when I [__]
run and the liquor store in town that's
why we thought this is also sauce you
guys listen we hate each other but it's
just talking doughnut and I wrote on
drunken who runs on drunken you are not
well who are you guys
in my purse probably is alright if
that's more news showing up Queen
Latifah looks first on the see you
and then KTLA decided to show up and
then NBC decides to show up they're like
alright well we can't let you guys have
all the fun so then NBC
last but not least we have I believe
it's CBS Wow welcome to the party
it's a really really exciting day in Los
Angeles I'm just saying we're pretty
excited even though we're really really
tired breaking news oh my gosh KTLA is
really miss out that sucks
but the news is here I mean it runs here
because of like your dreams because you
guys you're on first on the scene it's a
tent the tent is famous the sudden II
just are living in it it's amazing
the news is here thanks for inviting me
into your so so what does it been like
spending the night here it's been a
blast we have good company and so who is
the biggest Dunkin Donuts fan like one
yeah why you I have just had a lot of
iced coffee it's basically
he's got a great view over here News
News News News News News News so like
ready for bed
if I were to these people I've been
really nervous for you
they're gonna see me everyday everyday
I'll see you guys later here we are
rooster he's already in there I'm so
pumped I mean my camera was full oh my
gosh we need all of it
this is great I'm so excited I love
think about this and I'm still just so
nervous as you did it we did it
I got a vanilla bean colada now we you
know sandwiches okay we are now ending
this video we're leaving the junk and
donuts
it's time to go I'm exhausted all things
polite there you go look at this I am so
tired we've been here since 3:00 good
luck guys have fun wait how is it is it
good I gotta go get the car immediately
this is so exciting I'm done let's go to
bed